come on and stay with me first on CBS
mornings Airbnb is announcing new
updates to help its host deal with
Rising costs according to Airbnb which
has 4 million hosts worldwide about half
of hosts use money they earn from Arab
Airbnb to pay for items that have become
more expensive and about 1 in 10 have
used their earnings to avoid eviction or
foreclosure Airbnb co-founder and CEO
Brian chesky joins us now Brian good
morning thank you being here thank you
you put your own house up on Airbnb and
I want to get to that but first talk
about these updates to make things
easier for existing hosts yeah I mean
first of all we're seeing record demand
for travel on Airbnb and this is at the
time when the economy is slowing and so
we feel like a lot more people want to
turn to Airbnb to put their home on to
make extra money and we were started
during the Great Recession in 2008. so
we thought why don't we make it really
easy to put your home on Airbnb so now
we have a new product called airme setup
where we match you to a super host in
your area it's kind of like the Genius
bar but on your phone yes and they can
walk you through the process and we
provide this new product called air
cover which is top to bottom protection
so we're verifying the identity of
everyone on Airbnb starting this spring
if they come to your home and if
anything were to happen in your home
we'd protect you with three million
dollars of damage protection yeah so if
you're on the fence you're saying okay
now you got protection and you're gonna
know who the person is absolutely
absolutely you know uh before we get
into the lighter stuff I do want to ask
you uh about something that happened in
Mexico City just last week I'm sure you
know about it uh three Airbnb users died
of carbon monoxide poisoning it raises
the question and I know there's an
indicator when you book what's being
done to to make sure this just never
happens again well I mean like it was a
heartbreaking situation one death on
everybody's one death too many
we take safety really seriously it's
always my top priority what we do is we
will send free coo detectors to anyone
on Airbnb that needs one we've already
sent 200 000 to our community and I've
told our team we're going to get even
more aggressive to make sure everyone
complies everyone has the right safety
protections on their property and we
want to make sure people know what to
expect before they get to an Airbnb and
everything is advertised on the listing
that's why it's good to have the the
veteran Hostess
exactly and to make sure that that does
exactly because that was a very tragic
he's not a super host believe it or not
he's put his apartment on I'm just
starting from the ground zero I'm just
getting started now so and that's where
we've taken a turn by a big fan of your
work and and how you do your business
and how you move in the world but when I
heard that you were putting your own
home on yeah and I said well he's not
going to be there they go no he's
actually going to be out there so I want
to get this thing so you're saying to
people you can come and you can stay in
my house and I'm going to be there you
can go on Airbnb find my home you can
book it I will be there with you me the
guest and my golden retriever Sophie
Supernova the three of us are together
what are the accommodations like well
it's a really nice bedroom there's a
little bit of Airbnb history I'll make
you fresh uh cookies you can go to the
gym with me we'll take a walk to the
park there's a lot of fun things we'll
do are your parents aware that you're
doing this because they are fine I think
this is a good idea I decided I'd tell
you first so if they're watching they're
finding out now that that anyone around
the world can come and stay with me at
my house right now but Brian why are you
doing this it seems very risky to me
well I wanted to show people that's not
that risky I wanted to show people if I
the founder of Airbnb could do it then
you can do it as well and when we verify
the identity of everyone who books we're
having reservation screening technology
which uses some pretty Advanced machine
learning to make sure that we can take
signals of suspicious reservations to
block what we suspect by parties you
know we have 24 7 support so I feel
pretty good about it okay yeah I know
I've got I got a bedroom matching
onesies exactly a lot of fun I want a
book as well so you said cookies gym
walk in the park how's your waffle and
pancake game
we'll work on that okay all right great
Pop-Tarts oh Pop Tarts um I want to get
to another topic there's many tech
companies that are laying off employees
yeah
um where do you stand how is the brand
we know that it's thriving do you plan
on having any layoffs coming up no I
mean in 2020 the pandemic hit we lost 80
percent of our business in eight weeks
you thought you were going to lose the
company a lot of Articles where is this
the end of Airbnb but we got into motion
we unfortunately had to make some tough
decisions like doing layoffs back then
we stayed lean we stayed disciplined and
we are now very profitable so we are not
stepping on the brakes we're actually
stepping on the gas can I just ask
quickly your take on Elon taking over
Twitter it's been a little rocky for Mr
musk at this time yeah I know you know
him yes and I would just say like if
you're going to own Twitter you just
have to acknowledge that you're in the
community building business that's
probably be one of the biggest
communities in the world you know we
manage a community of hundreds of
millions of people when you do that you
just got to be listening to every
stakeholder and you have to find this
really interesting balance is that's a
really difficult job but I wish him the
best listen Twitter is like one big
Airbnb exactly a lot of people staying a
whole bunch of people a lot of opinions
you're right about that Brianna